ladies and gentlemen dear guests welcome
to this year's Neil wheeler Watson
lecture which is held by Professor
brunella to my name is Amelia and I am
director of the nobel museum who
organizes this lecture as an important
part of our ambition to be an
institution focused not only on
informing about science and research but
also an institution with an active
research department of our own before I
go on I will ask you all to shut down
your phones I hope you you all follow my
example yeah we are seated in the
fantastic Grand Hall of the stock
exchange now a part of the royal swedish
academy i would like to express my
gratitude to the academy for letting us
use this magnificent hall on these
occasions now this lecture would not
have been possible to arrange without
the generous support from Neil wheeler
Watson need you have been a true
supporter of our Museum ever since it
was founded and you have helped us shine
a few race of intellectual light upon
this frozen part of the world from time
to time from the bottom of my heart and
on behalf of everyone who sits here
today Thank You Neil dr. Paul Shalom and
his colleagues at the research
department here at the Museum have
worked hard with all the arrangement for
today thank you all for your fantastic
work before professor litter begins I
know that Paul has prepared a brief
introduction so Paul the floor is yours
thank you ola
brunella tools research and writings
constitute some of the most interesting
in their originality scope and ability
to capture perspective his collection of
works constitutes a radical and
comprehensive study a
recontextualization and call for the
re-evaluation of some of the most
important issues we face with regard to
the driving forces behind and functions
of Science and Technology modernities
historical influence the political
significance of globalization and the
ethical and moral consequences of the
ecological crisis with which we are
faced it is impossible for me to add
adequately capture summarize and present
the profound impact of Professor la
tools thinking here today of course
though the presentation of a few
selected examples from his work should
provide at least a glimpse of his its
enviable breadth and depth and hopefully
give a framework for today's lecture
Bruno Latour is a doctor of philosophy
and theology but for the majority of his
career as an anthropologist and
sociologist he has been working closely
with the education of Engineers he is
often associated with the
interdisciplinary field of science and
technology studies as well as with the
actor network theory to which he played
a significant role in formulating
however anyone who commits to reading
his works will quickly realize just how
difficult it is to place it within the
bounds of any one field to put it very
concisely professor la tools primary
interest lies in examining the
relationship between nature and culture
or more specifically in examining man's
problematic relationship to nature as
how I see it how we interact with nature
how we Society understanding an
interaction with nature formed and what
role does science play in this since its
initial ethnic
optical Studies on scientific
practitioners Bruno Latour has add her
to the basic postulate that our concept
of nature must be understood as a
product of rather than as the reason for
scientific praxis science is constructed
in processes on which both human
interests and non-human technologies
exert an influence within the framework
of a given historical social cultural
and political context that is why
science and politics technology and
society actor and structure are always
closely interlinked over the past decade
today's speaker has elaborated on
political theory implications from his
studies of science and his expanded
theory of modernity or maybe one should
say in modernity nature and culture have
been described in terms of a combined
ecological and parliamentary collective
in which the main question concerns how
to successfully live in peaceful
ecological coexistence in spite of
rather than thanks to science
definitions according to Latour
modernities unable assumptions of
reality and society as these entities
have traditionally been studied by
sociologists are obstacles in the way of
achieving this instead of simply
examining and reproducing assumptions of
reality and a society that consists
exclusively of people sociologists task
should be to trace the multiplicity of
perceived realities and heterogeneous
links between human and non-human actors
and interested parties it is the
discovery and description of these
perceptions of reality and networks if I
have understood professor Latour
correctly that can serve to identify the
problems and maybe also provide guidance
to a heterogenous but unified community
Bruno Latour impressive program is an
alternative brave and often also
provocative attempt to explain a hybrid
world in a constant
state of flux an approach that defies
all attempts at categorization according
to discipline theme and theory and
thereby succeeds in inspiring
researchers like many of us here today
to attempt to further pursue
cross-disciplinary experimentation it
may in fact be the highest praise we can
bestow upon our guest of honor that so
many leaders in the field of research
today are in unanimous agreement the
most important discussion application
and impact of Professor lateral thinking
is which is that which still lies ahead
of us so please allow me to extend a
warm welcome to the Neil wheeler Watson
speaker for 2010 bruno latour professor
and vice president for research at
l'Institut itude politic the body who
will speak on the topic may nature be
recomposed a few questions of Kozma
politics thank you